is captain america definitely done yeah
yeah i think it's done
i mean it was it was a great run and we
went out on such a high note
i mean what are the chances to have a
character span that long a time with
with that
much of a uh web of stories land on its
feet
uh in the final chapter and and to go
out on that note it would be
it would be it would be uh risky to
revisit in my opinion and and like i
said it was just such a good experience
um i think it's better just to be
left that way oh but very quickly i have
to say another movie we loved you in
was of course knives out all right that
movie
i mean it just went gangbusters didn't
it that movie yeah
yeah it did well i mean people love a
good murder ministry and it's one of
those genres that i don't think has been
explored
as much as maybe some other genres in
films so so i think people were really
excited about uh having one done really
well and as well as the plot you know
people love the plot of knives out they
love the characters
but they also loved the cable knit
sweater
yeah yeah they did i you know who
doesn't love a cable net
that's my favorite thing about living in
massachusetts you get a good
six-month window where a cable knit
works but no people went mad for it it
turned into headline news
everyone's going nuts over chris evans
knives out sweater chris evans is a
sweater is getting people hot and
bothered over knitwear
and i like esquire here's how you can
get chris evans very from nice
presumably you go to a shop
it's not rocket science well that's
that's my goal in my career to try and
let some sort of prop
or inanimate object do the heavy lifting
for me and then take all the credit
and presumably you can never wear one
again you know i
i i i do get a little bit of side eyes
when i wear one now it's a little bit of
like oh
god he's wearing a cable you know but
but i i figure a couple years i
i can't stay away but someone in your
family uh
can wear one how beautiful does dodger
know
he hated it he hated it and he looks so
good in it
but he he was that look is a look of
disgust
i think the thing he doesn't like is no
sleeves i think he feels
emasculated a cable that vest doesn't
quite have the same appeal does it
no talk about dark waters one of the
good things about
i guess for you talking about this film
is going in
we know dupont did it you can't spoil
this plot for us
because uh your experience on avengers
has
you've just you've had a litany of plot
spoilers
excuse me me
well i'm the best
you're marginally better than tom
holland but that's it yeah
what i taught tom holland
[Laughter]
tell us about the was it the premiere of
thor
uh okay come on you're wrong
it's all over now how are you they can't
fire you no they tried
so if you don't know this story uh this
is what happened
they asked me to do social media
backstage
and at that time it was like facebook
live had just
hit the um the apps and
um and so i um
i i was back there doing my facetime
facebook living
and um i thought i hit the off button
but i didn't realize it had two
different off buttons
and i went on when i ran to my seat they
started the movie i put my
my phone in my pocket and i'm sitting
there watching it and i'm like five
minutes in and my phone is blowing up
i'm just like and
everyone and their mother was texting me
from all over the world
to tell me that my phone was on and i
was live
broadcasting the
movie but of course
i'm a gentleman so i don't check my
phone
so finally they sent the lady down and
she
hey and i'm like what what and she's
like your phone
your phone is on i was like no it's not
it's it's in my pocket she's like
it's on it's on and i pulled it out and
i just like oh
[__]
i get a call from kevin feige oh the big
boss the boss
he's like what are you doing man
i said kevin i it was an accident i
swear to god they told me to use the
facebook live i don't know how to use it
he's like you can't do this stuff
i was like no no you're right sir
and the next day i showed up to do press
and i'm
i'm i'm hurting i i i can't look anyone
in the eyes
and i walk over to him to say sorry and
he grabs me in a bear hug
and he's like that was genius
we got more press from the whole
premiere
we couldn't imagine doing something not
good
all they heard was laughing and
you can't even escape free bag in the
house you're in can you because
the from series one the the wall of
penises
that's in your house she's in my house
yes they're all they're all here keeping
me company
are they close at hand can we have a
look they are they're actually they're
actually stored here while they're
waiting to go into the office right
because
because meant to be moving into my
office you know whenever lockdown is
over and i'm hoping it will eventually
become a hat stand or something
adorable like that um but this is this
is who welcomes people when they come to
the door
i mean they're quite i honestly don't
know what's happened to that one
you
a couple of months ago i mean you know
my sister and i live here and when we
put it there first we were like it would
be temporary and then you know when you
just put something down in your house
and then you don't
think about it for ages and it becomes
invisible to you and you forget that you
have like 12
massive penises at your front door thank
you
and this uh delivery guy came like a few
months ago
and opened the door and i just
completely forgot he kind of had to like
bring something in and he was like
knocking against the [__] as he was
coming in
he was like oh and then i was like oh
and i suddenly saw them again for the
first time in ages and i was like oh god
i'm
i'm so sorry and he just looked me dead
in the eye and he went it's art never
apologize for art
that was such a cool cool move from here
like over
all the time you haven't been doing it
the show as you guys were saying
never goes away it's constantly on
television
do you ever find yourself like drawn
into watching them
i don't look for it but uh
occasionally you know you're going yeah
uh and
oh dear there was one night in a hotel
somewhere
i'd flown in i had room ordered room
service
and i was flicking to and there was oh
star trek next generation
okay let's see what's going on i'll just
watch it for a couple of minutes
well i got hooked and then there was a
ring of the doorbell and my
my order arrived my room service order
arrived and the waiter came in
looked at me
i looked at the turbine and i thought
he's going to go away and tell the
entire kitchen
it is the saddest thing
this guy is upstairs alone having room
service
watching himself
[Laughter]
famous thank you
did you do that i you see it's always a
coincidence it's always that that that
little awkward moment for me was uh on
on on a plane you know sometimes like
when you're moving are playing on
on the airplane and you get up and go to
the bathroom or something you just look
at
you know the screens on the seats and
you're like oh that's me that's me
everybody on the plane is watching the
movie right now you hear sniffles and
people crying and stuff like that
but it's the walk back from the bathroom
as they're crying and looking up at you
we're trying to connect the two so it's
always i've had those little moments we
talked about the
being on hits you know you're on uh
grace is adam you're on killing eve
but there's another thing you're in that
people come up to ask you about isn't
there
which oh this is actually quite from the
from the past um when i it was actually
i think my first american movie
that i that i that i shot oh no no no
i'm thinking about
you know what i was thinking about mr
bean mr bean
who is obviously a very very very famous
character for you
um that that movie his first movie was
my very first
what my very first gig in america in
america you're in
you're in the mr bean movie dude i mean
i wish that you could just
show yeah right now i'm i'm in mr bean
it was my very first gig
uh in in la in on on a film in l.a so we
shot that
it must have been the fall of 95 and i
met rowan and uh harris yulin fantastic
cass
and peter peter mcnichol who is just a
genius
i was very young i was probably around
23 24
and i had just come to la and it was
recently on television
and i was like i cannot believe my hair
but that was
i got to tell you such a great
experience i there's a scene
when we're all together in a conference
room and
rowan is rohan was doing his thing and
we could
never get through a take we could never
get through a take and it was such a
great rich experience for me
um uh shooting that was my first america
first big film
okay we've got we've got the this is you
we found it
but this is this is so live you speak we
find
we've got the picture there she is
well that is elaborate hair but also
isn't it great
that you know because someone else might
have come to la and been in the mr boone
movie
but then never been in other things
so they don't get to look back and you
know enjoy it
it's interesting it's like when you just
if you can just hang on
if you can just stick around and hang on
it's amazing all the things that
oh you learned that come back to you and
that you can then you know
refer to many years later on your show
it's uh but i think the one that you
were talking about it was just a
um another one of my first uh uh uh
earlier american films was a film called
princess diaries with
and hathaway and the great um julie
andrews and
that's the one you played a vice
principle yes i
played i went through you know with
actors you can go through
seasons of things i played one at one
point from the early
did the mid to the late 90s all i played
were detectives
and then i got a lot of teachers
teachers and then i moved into doctors
but like a lot and then i moved into a
lot of like
a lot of people were wanting me to play
um uh
like psychiatrists and therapists and
then i would have to be very very
judicious
of of how many doctors i would play but
yes this was uh the character of a vice
principal and there's a line people like
you saying
for that movie and i haven't seen it
since but i remember it
this is the phone this is the phone okay
my very good
there's a very a good one theater school
the queen is coming i think that's the
one
beautiful it moved me i've got goose
bumps
now danny recklessly presumably you are
familiar with uh miriam's potty mouth
because
uh are you because you were in high body
but did you actually work together yeah
yeah yeah
yeah but i don't remember i've been told
there was a swear jar involved on set
but i
i can't remember that i don't you
remember you swearing a lot
i was probably careful when it was you
but when you know with the other kids i
didn't bother
he's the lead i was just talking
backstage if that's what you call that
funny little
girl
apparently it's 20 years since
harry potter came out the since we
started filming the the first one
and your balls have dropped since then
[Applause]
yeah but but it's interesting because
professor sprouse
which you know you were in the second
film and the last film yeah i should
have been in all of them
yes that was a grave oversight i'm
holding you responsible
but anyway it was wonderful to be in the
two that i was in and i'm very proud of
it but you do
get recognized as professor sprang i do
i i mean i think i've changed since then
but
people do recognize me and funnily
enough
in lithuania i was i'm
lithuan
have you come just to see professor
sprout i don't think so
are the films called professor sprout
no but i was mobbed in lithuania maybe
because i was jewish i don't know i'm
the only one there
sorry
but i just think that's incredible like
you're being mobbed in lithuania and
you're professor sprout
imagine being this one i know what what
was it like
i mean it's weird and funny and i think
like
the best way to see it always was like
weird and funny because it will it you
know and it ebbs and flows and sometimes
it's in your life a lot and sometimes
it's not in terms of getting recognized
and there's been lots of very
odd moments i was chased out of a
science museum in spain um and i was
just like but it was sort of fine
because everything was in spanish there
and i couldn't understand
anything inside so it was time to leave
anyway yes
and then uh but yeah but someone thought
you were something else in new york
recently oh yeah
you know what actually this didn't this
did not come up in in with it yeah
so i did recently so me and my
girlfriend fostered a dog
uh and it's we sort of got our friends
to adopt it this is not necessary for
the story there's a dog with me
um i i i was on the street with this dog
and my girlfriend was in the shop and so
i was it was very cold
i've got my hoodie and my fleece uh my
fleece hoodie and
then a big coat over that and the dog
was really cold so i was like i'll just
kneel by you and like stroke you and
like try and keep you warm and then uh
and then i saw this guy like look up at
me like 10 yards away and smile
and i was like and just carried on and
then he walked past me
and he came back uh like i got about
five steps past me then just reappeared
with a five dollar bill over my shoulder
and said get yourself a coffee mate
[Laughter]
i really like my girlfriend came out and
i was like i don't think i'm great i'm
like i'm
wearing nice clothes i thought like
yeah so i was i was very i that was a
wake-up call apparently i have to maybe
you know don't eat your dogs on a string
i do maintain because the person that
owns the dog has also been mistaken for
a homeless person with this dog
i think the dog just looks very cold and
sweet and vulnerable
i'm hungry yeah here's the thing this is
amazing so didn't the tour
sell out before your debut album came
out
yeah either how is that possible just
raw sex appeal
people saw a picture they went yes i
mean you look at me and you think
i'm gonna have a feast for the eyes
that's it yeah but like it's an arena
tour
lots of seats yeah lots of bombs and
seats and lots of money in my [__]
[Applause]
pocket
this is not my first glass of red wine
it's not me i'm having a good [__]
time
it's good to be here
you